we're going to start in atlanta because
there are fears this morning that a
string of deadly shootings at massage
parlors in the atlanta area
could be linked to a wave of attacks
against asian americans
following tuesday's tragedy in the
atlanta area celebrities are speaking
out against the ongoing racism against
asian americans police say it's too soon
to tell whether victims were targeted
because of their race
but the shootings do come during a
pandemic error surge in hate crimes
against asian americans stars have taken
to social media to denounce these
incidents
and offer their support joe jonas shared
this
heartbreaking figure from stop aapi hate
to his instagram stories
according to a report released by the
organization which was created in
response to anti-asian hate crimes amid
the pandemic
there have been 3795
incidents between march 2020 and
february 2021.
mindy kaling tweeted the targeting of
our asian brothers and sisters
is sickening but not surprising given
the normalizing of anti-asian hate
speech in the past year
we have to stop asian hate enough is
enough
kim kardashian wrote that seeing these
acts of violence breaks my heart
while mom kris jenner shared this
message where she said
these incidents are not something we can
ignore or excuse
lebron james tweeted his condolences to
the atlanta area
victims calling the acts of violence
senseless and tragic
dwyane wade shared this note on twitter
where he calls these attacks
heartbreaking and tells the asian
community we love you and are standing
with you
enough is enough on thursday daniel day
kim is scheduled to appear in front of
the congressional house committee on the
judiciary
where he'll speak about the rise of
discrimination and violence
against asian americans
you